tôt ce matin la police a effectué des
perquisitions dans la somptueuse
propriété de l'homme d'affaires gilles
fontaine la villa caprices dans quelles
conditions ce domaine at il été acquis
en 2017
mais il s'appelle l'avocat à l'autre la
jarne où je me dépasse jamais chez un
client pour un premier entretien je me
déplaçais méchas fillon pourra premier
entretien d'albert une poule de luxe
non excusez moi mais c'est souvent
monsieur chanter
mais de charge il le sait il en joue
je peux encore dit oui bien sûr j'ai dit
oui
regardez moi cette merveille germain
[Musique]
26 ma famille
désolé de vous connaître
prenez garde à vous mais sait jamais
[Musique]
vous partez du principe que le juge a
toujours un coup d'avancé au bout
sommes ici pour examiner les conditions
dans lesquelles vous avez acquis une
propriété
mais très précieux à vous savez
très précieux
vous allez être mis en examen pour
fraude
non conforme kampala ah mais c'est
beaucoup moins cher
toujours pensé que cette saison serait
un monde où
[Musique]
votre 10 en puissance est un leurre on
vous paye pas vous achète
[Musique]